the jurgen experience
well
somebody pointed out and it's a good
point how do we have 40 billion dollars
to send to ukraine and we don't have 40
billion dollars to protect the schools
okay exactly how do we where's the money
getting out but i've said this about
every single problem they have in this
country every time there's like a report
on the shootings in chicago like how do
we have money
to send to other countries when we don't
have enough money to fix whatever's
going on the south side of chicago or
baltimore or
how's it going to detroit if we have if
we have this money how does it how is it
poverty right in this right okay so you
find money for for for other things but
you don't find money to correct the
problems here exactly exactly it's
almost like
well it has to be it's almost like it
has to be profitable like you remember
when we invaded iraq and halliburton got
these no-bid contracts to fix all the
[ __ ] we blew up
[Music]
give them a no bid contract
to fix chicago go in there fix it go in
there set up set up community centers
set up whatever you can do to protect
people set up whatever you can do to
educate people set up whatever you can
do to provide people with better housing
make give them hope
country the whole country the whole
country it can be like if you've got
that much money to go into these other
countries and fix things
and this whole idea of us being the
police of the world how the [ __ ] can we
be the police of the world we can't even
police our own backyard how do i have a
i have a plan
to eradicate homelessness
but
the smartest people in this in this
world don't have a plan what's your plan
simple so yeah in most in most cities
you have these abandoned buildings you
have a lot of abandoned buildings you go
in
you refurbish this building and you
start people
right at the top and it's a tier system
that
as you you tear out the door so whatever
your situation is whether it's mental
health
you get that fixed there whether it's
financial literacy you get that fixed
there whatever your situation is you get
fixed in this building that this is what
this this recovery center is for
then you put you put them in jobs in
within the within the building because
it's great it's ran by grants within the
building to heighten the skills that
they already have you and you ask you
what are their interests what do they
want to be what were you before this
happened to you how did this happen you
get all that back information and as as
as they are tearing out the money that's
allocated for each particular
client
through this grant
half of that money is being
put to the side for when they get ready
to come out that they're you're not lit
you're not letting them out of this
program
just naked with just the skills that
they acquired in this program you're
giving them a lease on a new lease on
life this is the money that you acquired
by being by being through this program
let's help you start let's help you
start your life from this point and you
invest in the businesses that they're
that they're starting you're investing
in life whether it's a trade center you
invest in these people and with the with
the notion of they're going to reinvest
a percentage back into the building to
help more people and you keep recycling
people back into the world in that in
that in that manner so when you see
somebody homeless they're like i'm
homeless i can't help myself they're
like [ __ ] it's a building right
there that helps every single person
that even falls on hard time and then
you give people free health care i bet
if you did that for several generations
you could put a massive debt in it i
don't think you'd ever totally fix it
because you're never going to fix
abusive parents
sexual abuse drug abuse when you get
people you get people out of them you
get people out that situation because
the
i was in a i had an abusive stepfather
the only way to remedy this
is to get out of this because you can't
fix him you got to you got to focus on
me yeah and get me to
safety but if you [ __ ] somebody
thinking that somebody
you put a person in a position where
they feel like they need that person and
so you make excuses for their behavior
when i see this all the time and people
like what why did this person stay why
did this person do this because if they
were handicapped they was crippled and
when you feel like you have no other
place to go you stay in positions that
that that's abusing you
that's what people do
that's definitely true but the amount of
resources you would have to have to take
care of every family where every person
is being abused we have it because we
can give it we can give it we we we
throw away more food in this country
than more countries than most countries
produce in a year our waste our waste
ratio if our waste ratio change then our
condition change
yeah because if you allocate if you
allocate funds to the right thing
instead of wasting funds
like even even with even with this
it's a it's it's people say it's a
misinformation in certain things yes it
is when you when the federal government
doesn't allocate funds to certain people
to eradicate the misinformation
in me and media
in media it's federal funds that go that
go out to media companies why you don't
give that to some to some of the black
media outlets that you say that don't
know what's going on because you're not
helping you're not helping the situation
either you're hurting the situation
you're saying that
people's number if you know that the
number one thing that cripples people in
this country is health
and then you don't make it
where they can have quality free health
care in this country then you don't feel
like the consumer
that your your your
the human being
is the most important commodity
on this planet
if you invest in the human being
and the human being
does
the good works that he's supposed to do
with that investment and they invest in
more human beings you create this utopia
of
helping
and learning and not being and not
having a phobia of hey joe i need your
help that doesn't make me less than a
man because i need your help with
something
you you supposed to give your fellow man
uh a leg up that's what you're supposed
to do yes but we we live in the what i'm
not supposed to do
yeah and helping people feels good it's
good for you too that that's one thing
we have to get into people's heads
helping people feels good it's good for
you too